we've got a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question from a caller about
the intellectual dark web which we spoke
about last week and Marxism take a
listen to this hey David I just had a
quick theory I wanted to share with you
and it's basically this um so with all
these intellectual dark web types you
know really hating on Marx and all this
that's been going on I I hadn't really
read much of March knew much about what
Marx actually said but because I have an
aversion to people like Dave Rubin and
Petersen and stuff like that I you know
it's caused me to actually look into
Marx more and I wonder if their
fear-mongering about Marx is going to
lead to more people with the end of
March the source material rather than
just taking their word for what he says
or complaining it with things like
maoism or just all in ISM yeah I think
that there's a lot to that and I don't
so the question is is the intellectual
dark web by slamming things like Marxism
turning more people over to Marxism some
of whom say there were some interesting
ideas here I don't know if the
intellectual dark web is doing that but
what we do know is that over the last
five years socialism has become much
more accepted particularly in society at
large in the United States but also
specifically among younger generations
now except that doesn't mean that there
are all advocates view that these are
all advocates of socialism but it means
that some of the precepts and some of
the concepts of socialism or Marxism or
whatever are not sort of on their face
of no meaning value or sort of worth a
discussion or consideration so I think
that the intellectual dark web you know
if you hear the intellectual dark web
types slam Marxism and you
unquestioningly accept it you probably
were already of that mindset to begin
with and there's a chance that it you
would say you know I don't really know
anything about Marxism let me look into
it and you might inadvertently turn some
people over to the ideology or at least
into considering it so I think that
there is something to that and the data
reflects that which is that these ideas
populism as well as a sort of extension
of democratic socialism or social
democracy are more popular than they've
been in a very long time whether it's
the IDW or not I couldn't really say I
think it's usually used as a misnomer
though I think most Millennials wouldn't
necessarily identify a socialist they
would identify a Social Democrats kind
of socialist sure and so people in the
intellectual dark web people on the
right in general can just you know put
it all in the same group oh you're a
socialist that means you're a communist
and you know your system with it yeah
there now which would be the full
extension yeah I agree with you and
there's a lot of straw Manning going on
I think to take a term that has become
very popular on the right we've got a
great bonus show for you today we'll
talk about Bernie Sanders writing for
re-election and much much more get
access to the bonus show by joining now
at join pakman.com or on patreon at
patreon.com slash david pakman show